Just Cause 3 makes no apologies for it's
outrageous nature it's a power fantasy
in every sense of the phrase placing you
in a world right with destructible
environments and giving you instruments
with which to destroy them there are
intermittent technical problems and
scripted moments to track from the
freedom found elsewhere but in the end
Just Cause 3 presents a spectacular
sandbox experience it's a testament to
this game's creativity that guns were
often my last resort like all of Just
Cause threes best moments the tether
encourages experimentation rather than
thoughtless reaction and as the hours
passed the destruction stayed fresh Just
Cause 3 excels because it adds variety
to the equation throughout making
destruction and mayhem entertaining far
past the early hours however Just Cause
3 does deviate from its open world
freedom at times and what it does it
falters the scripted story missions
progress the plot but the actual
gameplay involved is repetitive at best
and broken at worst Just Cause 3 can be
a game of experimentation and foresight
and the results are as rewarding as they
are entertaining and it rarely gets old
down with the jet